voter's braved the rain to cast their
ballots here in demacian southern malawi
apart from the weather the election has
been smooth here president Banda can
look to areas like this for backing out
in a countryside the government's
development projects and farm subsidy
schemes are popular in April Baldwin
development we've seen needs to continue
that's why I'm here never forgot I'm
voting for someone who makes food
available and fertilizer affordable
bandas reputation has been damaged in
recent months that's mainly because of
what's known as the cashgate scandal
government officials allegedly siphoned
off tens of millions of euros that's hit
foreign aid donations which normally
count for as much as forty percent of
the budget Banda says she needs more
time to fight corruption and I was
advised that seven months before
elections was too short for me to tackle
corruption because the people that are
benefiting from it they will fight you
back no simulator on to you they'll
bring you down you may never get out
bandas main challenger is Lazarus
chakwera an evangelical pastor who's
running for the Malawi Congress party he
accuses bandas government of corruption
and doing too little to lift people out
of poverty other candidates have accused
bandas government of plots to rig the
vote although foreign diplomats say they
see no evidence of that bandas unlikely
to do well in the cities but this
election will be decided out in the
countryside which is home to eighty
percent of malawi's 16 million people